all right well I got to mention this
folks for a while now we've been doing a
segment on our program called
Frankenstein waste a minute of our time
[Music]
in this segment in this segment
Frankenstein comes out here acts as if
he has something really cool to show us
he's very excited but he always ends up
showing us something trivial and stupid
it's a complete waste of time and not at
all exciting well tonight Frankenstein
has promised me give me his word that he
really does have something amazing to
show us something pretty cool and
electric
he claims it's fantastic so I'm gonna
believe him let's get him out here and
have Frankenstein waste a minute of our
time
[Applause]
[Music]
I bring it son are you are ready to
waste a minute of our time ah okay are
you promised you have something really
exciting to show us this time
[Music]
great then Frankenstein show us what
you've got
set it backstage
behind he said okay look he's headed
back through the sort of props area
backstage area past where the music
loads in he's headed back towards those
are sort of where the dressing rooms are
I don't know where he's going and it's
headed for okay
[Applause]
we don't want to feel like
[Applause]
you guys are
inside
very nice very well done we'll take a
break when we come back
[Applause]